what the is going on I like to party
Jesus honey wax this is unwaxed get in
lizard we're going shopping with Sophia
and cine Salone did we just become best
friends
[Music]
y hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sisters Sophia and
cinee you guys we're still in our
pajamas it's just one of those days it's
one of those days no kidding Miami I
know shocker well you were just saying
that you're on this whole Health Journey
for the next year yeah funny enough I
had a little stint you know how
sometimes you have this idea or this
goal that you set for yourself one
random morning and then you say you know
what I'm going to dedicate because I
want to see results in two months I'm
going to do it I had that last week
right and I said my goal for the next
year is to be slim thick bear with me
excuse me I'm built like Slender Man
naturally right it's fine wait can we
just say that um when she was in high
school she got bullied and people called
her the pre Manis Let Me Go a step
further with that
story here's
context I have the body of SpongeBob
squir pants fine there's no curvature
there it's just Square more no more like
no it's it's lean and long but it's just
Square more like a seaweed stock like
the ones that just you know just like
long a piece of seaweed yeah long and
skinny in school in high school actually
not even Middle School these people are
grown enough to know this is not okay I
got made fun of a lot I don't know why
um also I was very underdeveloped but
that's another story these guys made an
Instagram account I cannot remember the
name of it but I still have screenshots
one day I'm coming for all of you okay
one of you was a redhead I remember your
name I won't Andrew I remember you got
it all right and they made an Instagram
account yeah and they every single day
would find a photo that I posted maybe I
was in a bathing suit by the pool really
happy and they would Photoshop it next
to something they thought I looked like
in that photo one being a prantis it was
really bad I mean one at the time it was
bad now it's funny one being Slender Man
so every every day I would wake up on my
phone Instagram I had for about a year
now and I would just see this harassment
it was torture so yes my goal for the
next year the story comes full circle
yes I said I want to be one of those
girls because I follow all these Tik Tok
Instagram girlies that just have their
workout routines so jam-packed perfect
and they have the best legs and the best
butts and and they really put in the
time they track their macros I don't
even know what a macro is they track
their protein intake all this stuff so I
went to Target the other day I got the
Pre-Workout I got the protein powder
they use I said okay I wrote a schedule
for myself how I'm going to lift how
much I'm going to lift I did it for one
day one day and I said you know it kind
of hurts my tummy so I stopped yeah oh
okay see that you know what's really
frustrating about you is that you make
the excuse of having your tummy hurting
for everything if you're nervous for a
date if you can't have this certain
protein powder makes your tummy hurt
it's like everything makes your tummy
hurt you make my tummy hurt exactly an
excuse everything makes your tummy hurt
so you know what else makes my tummy
hurt love which is what we wanted to
talk about today how good of the
transition was that you can't say it's a
good transition um yeah butterflies in
your tummy that does make sense so cinee
and I last week technically it's going
to be last week by the time we shot this
we wanted to talk about something that
we've always been very proud of which is
giving great advice about dating and
love not saying look we're not saying
that we're examples of you know figuring
it out but I will say cuz we don't take
our own advice but we have a little
sister yeah and cinee and I said to each
other you know I personally being the
oldest I wish I had an older sister or
two that went through the things that
Scarlet's going through that can talk me
off a cliff so many of my decisions that
I could have avoided that I could have
made better with just you know the
proper instructions 100% we have to give
credit to Scarlet for this because she
listens to all of our episodes thank you
and she said the one thing I feel like
you guys are missing is you talk about
stories you talk about dates you talk
about your life but you never give clear
examples of what to do when if this
happens how do you handle it and she
goes you guys give such good advice why
don't you do that so we've decided that
we have a whole list of listener
questions I haven't even gone through
them yet and we're just going to help
you guys out answer some of these
questions and again I know what you're
thinking sinee Sophia you're both
single why would you be qualified to
talk about
relationships I agree listen everything
we're saying is our opinion please take
it with what you want I read romance
books is a WR characters end up with
each other in the end so I would argue
that we're actually the perfect Duo to
do this and we have been classified in
our friend group as the therapist yes
okay yes that's true Sophia is overly
romantic overly into love movies and
books and music and cinee is the one
that was going to give you the hard
truths and she doesn't beat around the
curve so if you're doing something wrong
she's telling you and I think I've
crossed one too many F Boys in my life
so I know how to handle these characters
so we're just going to start reading
some off yeah we'll see what happens
we'll see these are all questions you
guys have asked so this is nothing that
we've just made up and I really like
this because we haven't done anything
like this in dedicated an episode just
all about love and it's great timing
because it's going into the new year so
maybe you can take these little nuggets
and maybe weekend too yeah truly I'm
going to rewatch this episode yes okay
so we'll start with the first question
and it is is it wrong for me to have guy
friends if I have a boyfriend
see I already know how I feel there's
the correct answer and then there's the
answer that I feel about and I think
it's the same one yeah of course you
should feel secure enough in your
relationship
that gender of friends shouldn't matter
but if you're like us and you're a we
bit crazy and a we bit suspicious all
the time I do think there is a limit to
too many girl or guy friends MH what do
you think that number is
no I don't think there's even a number
maybe two no this is what I think is
it's the same thing with you personally
I think it's fine that you have a guy
friend absolutely I do because cine has
really good guy friends I don't
personally have really close guy friends
I've just I've always been a very much a
girls girl um and I know that if cinee
had a boyfriend she'd still want to be
friends with some of her guy friends
that she's close with but there's a
boundary if your best guy friend becomes
The Confidant that your boyfriend should
be and probably wants to be then I would
say that's where the issue lies so I
would really make sure you communicate
that with your boyfriend or just make
sure you're aware that what if he was
talking about all his feelings and all
his things that he would probably want
to talk about you with with a girl I
would also argue I think the only reason
that I have functioning guy friends for
as long as I have is because there was a
strict boundary set in place since day
one sorry I don't believe that if you
cross that line from Friendship into
something more wink wink there's really
no putting the toothpaste back in the
tube there so I think that's the pretty
much the only way you can have a
functioning friendship with a guy I do
also want to say that my ex had a lot of
girlfriends all of which hated me for no
reason yeah so yeah I didn't love that
and I think that if they're your
cheerleader and your supporter then
absolutely you guys should all be
friends but I think everyone's got a
little bit of agenda a little bit of
jealousy so you really got to it's it's
yeah it's tough to it's very specific
for each relationship yeah that's our
opinion okay why does he keep coming
back and then leaving me on red yeah on
open like I guess what they were saying
is why does he keep coming back you know
talking to you and then the moment you
respond he goes away because shank shank
sh people want what they can't have and
I'm telling you right now I've been in
this exact situation for the past seven
years with one person oh my God you know
who you are true every time I call him
he doesn't answer if he calls me and I
answer he has nothing to say if he calls
me and I don't answer he gets mad at me
now I say what do you want what are the
games and I've realized do I actually
want to spend a single minute with him
or without him even thinking about him
no you want to be with someone that is
UN
shamelessly going after you is not
afraid about it isn't trying to be too
cool for school because at the end of
the day
like you know I always have the time for
you know what I always Envision and just
like to end the question because
obviously I think that was the best
answer you could have given period you
have you SE have you ever seen the movie
My Best Friend's Wedding with Julia
Roberts and um Cameron Diaz and and I
forgot the guy but he's super handsome
Grant no different different ' 8s 90s
guy so basically there's a scene where
the bride Cameron is running the groom
is running after her and then Julia
Roberts is chasing him and her best
friend basically says to her who's
chasing you if there's all these people
chasing each other who's behind you
chasing you so if you're looking back
and there's no one
there stop texting that boy move on okay
how do you cope with the pressure of
finding a partner just turned 30 and
haven't found my person oof okay CU we I
because I look I'm 27 so not too far off
from you and I have the same pressures I
think and I put on myself a lot and I
read a lot about this stuff just to kind
of reinforce the fact that things happen
in life for a reason there's a reason
why certain relationships didn't work
out there's always a path there's a
reason why you're not with someone right
now I mean look if you're putting in the
effort great like keep putting in the
effort mom says all the time dating is a
job you put in all your time and all
these other things and if you're not
putting in time for dating then you know
things probably won't work out but you
shouldn't feel the pressure
because what I'm going stop you right
there Sophia you cannot give advice to
someone about feeling pressure about not
being in a relationship when you feel
the pressure all the time I just said I
always feel the pressure I watch this
old woman on Tik Tok she's fabulous I'll
link her name below she's constantly
giving advice for people in their mid
20s early 30s and I think when you're in
your 30s and you're in your early 20s
you're always around those people the
same people your age and you see them
moving on in life and progressing in
life and you feel stuck cuz it's always
around you it's all you think about it's
all your friends it mean it's it's
constant now I watched this old woman
and I feel like I can take her advice
the most because she's lived it she's
lived a long life she's not in her early
30s anymore she always
says the one thing that I
regret at this age was I was constantly
putting this pressure fear and timeline
on my life and now she's like I'm 90
years old looking back it was the
biggest waste of time because it panned
out exactly the way I wanted it to if
you want something enough in life it's
going to happen for you so just don't
put a time stamp on it because the only
thing you're going to be doing is
driving yourself insane also speaking
from someone who's actually in their
late 20s cuz sine doesn't get it yet
she's in her mid 20s hey don't be
jealous um when I was feeling this
pressure I actually this sounds so
random but if anyone knows who Sarah
Blakeley is this knows I really respect
her I love her she's the founder and
owner of Spanx and I've watched her
master classes on how she built her
Empire but one thing she said when she
was talking about a relationship was
that she was in her early 30s and she
had this massive growth of a company and
she said the one thing I never put
pressure on myself was Finding Love and
I focused on myself becoming the best I
could be focused on my work focused on
my friendships and she said she just had
this gut feeling that it just would
happen eventually and at 34 she met the
love of her life they have four kids
together and they've been married ever
since mhm so it can happen
it can happen later in life and it can
happen for me it can happen for you o
this next question is tricky when is it
appropriate to sleep with someone you're
seeing that it doesn't scream
easy I think this is so personal to each
person I think three you think three
dates yeah I if I'm just going to give a
if you guys just want a blunt answer for
me I think three dates is pretty much a
SE number would say three to five in my
head in my head this is how I always
thought thought and there's of course
the opposite end of this but I always
thought the longer you wait the more
respect they'll give you and now that
I'm getting older I don't necessarily
agree with that because I've heard
stories of people the first night
they're going home together and they're
married with kids so it really doesn't
matter I think it is more important of a
question to
ask why are you questioning whether this
person will respect you or not if you
did the certain natural thing mhm maybe
don't be with that person then
yeah period um how do you not get
attached so quickly I think I'm pretty
good at this um CU sine gets attached
really quickly I'm like velcro she's Vel
girl I you know I'm actually a slowburn
people think that because I love love so
much that I am someone that was going to
dive into like the next relationship I'm
pretty good at separating I would say my
feelings from someone to emotional to
whatever and I would say for myself I'm
I think it's good to keep your guard up
and that's what really helps me not get
so attached so quickly I don't try
immediately to fantasize about this
person 247 if I of course I get my
nerves like nerves happen when he texts
me I get butterflies if I I'm going on a
date with him but I think that until I
feel a moment in the relationship where
I go oh this one's going to be different
until then he's just your friend that
you find attractive like this is just
someone you're trying to get to you
cannot read too much into it like even
if you're kissing even if you're doing
stuff I mean at the end those are your
choices it's your body it's your life
you can't think that this person has any
control over it and that's really what
it is I'm not going to lie as well you
kind of have
to weigh the option that they might be
doing the same thing with someone else
so until you've got this person locked
down you shouldn't get too attached
because again it's it's still early on
if you start catching yourself
fantasizing about what the future's
going to look like like stop think of
dates as like doctor's appointments in
this way no hear me out hear me out yeah
this is kind of how I Envision it when
I'm in the beginning stages of not
trying to get attached too quickly in
the sense that my life goes on I still
hang out with my friends I still do my
job I don't have my mind swarmed with oh
I need to go on this what is he doing
what is he doing I think of it his oh
there's an appointment set a date I'm
going to go on it we're going to enjoy
our night and then I move on and then up
happens again oh we're texting a little
bit more and then that's when you start
to fall for someone just yeah you know
just separate the the heart a little bit
from what it really is there you know I
agree yeah this person said I just ended
a four-year relationship should I start
on dating apps in which ones no
yes no first of all it's called let's
talk to the girl that is on the apps and
the girl that won't be on the apps yeah
and I just went I guess it wasn't four
years if you feel like you are ready to
put yourself out there again and you
want a fast pass to dates absolutely now
I can't guarantee you're going to meet
someone
worth value sorry on these dating apps
but I do think dating apps are fun for
me because it's sort of
like dating is like a a workout right
you have to rework that muscle and
you've been in a relationship for 4
years so going back out there and seeing
the different types of men or women that
you're going to encounter like it's a
whole new world cuz you're so used to
one thing for so long so I think yes if
you feel like you're ready and you just
want to have fun and get dressed up why
not but I will warn you and I think this
is what's really hard getting out of a
long relationship with someone that you
probably loved really deeply is that you
come to this kind of cruel realization
that these guys aren't looking at you
with the love and affection that
probably your exed and that's going to
be really trippy because you're so used
to one way yeah and and um we saw that
on a show last night where the girl had
ended a really long relationship and she
was sleeping with this guy and she goes
I just miss you know the affection and
holding of someone that I was you know
that loves me it looks at me lovingly
and you know if you're just doing it to
kind of get just get back out there
absolutely join a dating app but I also
think it's really okay to you know pause
for a couple months like six months and
you know be with your girlfriends yes I
have no advice on which one to join I'm
still figuring that out myself I have
never used Bumble or any of them so okay
he cheated on his girlfriend with me he
told me he was single oh should I tell
her I found
her
yeah um hold
on o first of all screw that guy yes
second of all I'm sorry that you got
lied to and that you're not put in the
situation because anyway people people
look at it it could seem like
you're the bad person in the scenario
you're not and that really sucks if I
was the girlfriend I'd want to know I
will tell you this every time I've heard
a scenario of the other woman who found
out that he was like found out or she
was sleeping with someone that was in a
relationship that had told the partner
they've always gotten the respect after
they don't get on truly they get
actually the thank you so much for
telling me answer look it's it's up to
her if she wants to continue that
relationship but I think you know you
might be saving her from something
really bad damn I can't even imagine if
that was my my advice burn the house
down next question my significant
other my significant other wants me to
be more vocal about my feelings how can
I learn to speak up
ooh
o okay how do I start
this
I don't have this problem because I feel
like I'm almost actually you know why
that's not true I think that don't you
feel like this we are such vocal people
but when it comes to being in a
relationship it's really hard to say
what me mean and mean what we say you
know do you know what I'm saying we're
trying to almost hide how we feel about
things so it just doesn't through a lot
of self-reflection when I was going
through that I always found myself
asking what about me speaking my true
feelings to this person that I like or
even love is so scary and I think you
need to address that with yourself first
is it a fear of rejection is it
something that you haven't healed from
in the past because there's nothing
greater than showing vulnerability in a
relationship it's only going to make you
guys stronger it's only going to make
the relationship
stronger learn to speak up I think maybe
try something that makes you feel
comfortable and it's sort of a baby step
into it maybe if that's saying how you
feel through a letter so you don't
physically have to say the
words well how else would you start into
it you know it's tough and I I'm more of
a very blunt person when it comes to
things I think if it came for me
speaking on my emotions I'm definitely
someone that just goes you have to just
rip the bandaid off and go hey I really
need to talk to you about something and
I want no judgment just listen let me
speak I could be going on a word vomit
and a word tangent and not really know
what I'm saying and speaking circles but
let me just get to my point and I think
it sometimes you don't need to be
responded to you just need to be heard
when it comes to feelings I used to make
my ex hide under the covers when I told
him how I feel just so he wouldn't look
at me wait what just so he wouldn't look
at me cuz I'm like I don't want to see
your face I just want to speak he's like
told yeah he would or he'd put his face
in a pillow by the way it worked it
worked and I got out what I needed to
say okay tell him to crawl under the bed
yeah and put a mask on and then go duck
close his eyes duck tape perfect oh god
um any funny stories about being
rejected you're looking at me like I've
got all the stories I don't I'm trying
to think if I have had any funny this is
so bad um just can't think of fun right
now I have to say
humbly this year I've been ghosted more
than I've ever been in my life thank
you new word for Ghost
and I want to apologize to all the men
I've ghosted doesn't feel good it
doesn't feel good no um funny stories
about being rejected
though you know what it is I don't want
to I'm not going to say that this is a
good story oh okay I was going to say
I'm not acting like I don't get rejected
I just don't usually put myself in the
position of potentially getting rejected
like I don't usually if that makes sense
like I I'm not sure if this is a
rejection story but this is along those
lines years ago when we were living in
La Sophia and I got invited to
this young Hollywood event oh you know
the story you know the story yes I do
know the story and we got styled for the
event it was the worst styling ever I
don't know why the stylist put Sophia in
a shimmer mermaid tight dress with a
giant pink fur coat like I was like I
was mamore it gets better pink she put
me in parachute pants that were black
and yellow sequent flowers the whole
thing and then a sheer striped black and
yellow top I looked like a bumblebee you
look like a g i look like a rated
Goodwill I just it was bad it was
horrible anyway I had just broken up
with my first boyfriend at this time I
think I was 19 18 and I just joined Rya
so I'm on Rya whatever no prospects we
go to this event
and I see one of the guys that I had
matched with on riot at the event
obviously I don't say anything because
I'm so insecure and I look like a
bumblebee so I'm just minding my own
business he notices us doesn't say
anything fast forward the next day he
messages me on the app you looked so
beautiful at the event last night
Bumblebee out I would love to take you
out I said the man wants the honey
amazing let's go on a date
he picks me up you want to know what he
said to
me I just couldn't stop staring at you
in that pink fur coat in the sequent
dress I
said what do you mean because I was
clearly wearing black and
yellow I looked like a
bee and I said that no I was that wasn't
me and he goes no you had this the fur
coat and the pink little dress and I
said no sir that was my sister you took
out the wrong sister do you want me to
call her we can make a little swap here
end of that yeah funny enough we ended
up going on a few more dayses after that
but toally wasn't reject well that's all
I say rejection is God's protection I
burned the pants okay next one is it you
or me I can go how to stop getting the
ick I get the ick so quickly I remember
a story where sine got mad at me because
there was a guy that was so nice this is
years ago and um we were getting along
like a house on fire and um I went home
and sine goes you should go on a date
with him and I said I couldn't and
remember how I said that it was because
he wore
flipflops it's so dumb to be fair he
lived near the beach yeah yeah I know it
was like the dumbest excuse ever and I
was like that's the example if your ick
is something as dumb as flipflops then
grow up I'm sorry grow up I mean there
no reason
to but that's no reason to write someone
off right it's the same as if
we say oh you're a Capricorn can't date
you like that's just not nice but if
it's
something I would say hygiene wise or
something that really just is a deal
breaker for you I'm so sorry once you've
caught the ick it's irreversible yeah
yeah yeah you can't stop but if it's
something stupid like
flip-flops it's you know what it is deal
with it this is I think the worst thing
to think about people have EXs of you
that you don't even realize what do you
think my EXs
are I don't
oh what how every time you laugh you
go I just did it again it's not even bad
I just thought of like you going like
this all the time um I think that's
it wait
oh there's more
um actually yeah that's pretty much it I
think okay next question do I have any x
no you're perfect you say something to
me no you have X but I can live with
them and that's the lesson here how to
ask a girl out that is too
shy I don't know I don't how do to ask a
girl that's too shy okay um what I would
do what I would do oh I
know you know she's shy but you're
probably liking her enough to notice
little things that she likes maybe it's
reading maybe it's dinosaurs I don't
know what chy girls like was a joke what
a casually start conversation with her
about things that interest her so then
she opens up her walls a little bit
there's more comfortable banter this is
one of those things shy girls are things
you have to chip away at a little bit
it's going to take some grafting but
they'll eventually crack I also think if
you don't know her personally and maybe
you've seen her from afar a really good
way is to use social media because it's
not a direct face to face it's something
kind of a little bit more on the side
where it's not as in your face also I'd
like to say this I was very very very
shy growing up and no one asked me out
in high school because I was so shy and
quiet that doesn't mean I didn't want to
be asked out I think you never know
sometimes the shy ones are the sneaky
ones and I think every girl thinks
that's a huge compliment and that's a
huge form of
flattery see maybe you thinks she's shy
but maybe she's just quiet that's the
same thing it's kind of different it's
kind of different my boyfriend and I
have been together for over a year and
there's no honeymoon we're fighting more
what can I do I don't want to break up
okay let's break this down my boyfriend
and I have been together for over a year
so honeymoon phase is gone and we're
fighting more what can I do I don't want
to break up we should use the advice we
just recently gave you know what's so
funny I always feel like at the
six-month Mark and at the year
mark That's when things get the worst
fights happen for me well I yeah it's
when it's when the honeymoon phase is in
and then the rosecolor glasses are off
and the two of you have been with each
other day in and day out and it's where
the little XS develop and it's where the
things that just you know would piss you
off if it was your sibling and you can
get away with that are Just Happening
Now with someone that you're really
comfortable with and we gave this advice
the other day and this actually worked
this worked so what we basically said
cuz we can kind of do it together um we
said that when these little bickers and
fights happen constantly because when it
happens and I had this too at the end of
a relationship sometimes it's not for
everybody but sometimes anything that
they do just irks you they don't text
you on time they they avoid messaging
you when they're out they they're
breathing they're yeah there anything
they could they could just look at you
the wrong way or make a comment about
your outfit and it even if it's not
intended to be bad and vice versa where
maybe they're doing something or they
feel like something from you so it
becomes this back and forth and the
point of it is there's a lot being said
but nothing being said yeah and what
there only needs to be said is exactly
how you're feeling it kind of goes back
to the first question that we just had
we told this
person you guys are constantly having
these little bickers and going in a
circle but you're not actually finding a
resolution here so we told this person
be the bigger person go up to your
partner sit them down and be very clear
and concise when you say let's just take
a breather not break up let's take a
breather right now I'm going to say
everything that is Weighing on me
everything you do that kind of bothers
me everything that I feel is not making
this relationship as strong as it should
be and I don't want you to interrupt
then you're going to say all the things
that I'm doing that bother you for
example one of them would be I want you
to text me when you get home or one
would be you know every single morning I
want a good morning text things like
that and when this person called us
after they said that literally changed
the entire mood the entire energy
because I think a lot of times in
relationships you feel so strongly about
your opinion but you often don't notice
what you're doing to make the other
person upset as well I think there also
comes a lot of insecurities the longer
in a relationship and it's hard because
you're it's not long enough in the
relationship where you want to verbalize
those insecurities but it's not short
enough you know it it just becomes this
whole melting stirring pot of emotions
and I think at the end of the day when
you have a partner and when you're
having this sit down conversation
talking about everything that has just
been bothering you you just want to be
heard you don't want to be judged and
you don't want emotions tied into it
they can respond but when if you're
hearing it and you're getting a response
or you are responding make sure you
remember this is how they're feeling
this is not them accusing this is not
them unless you're doing something that
is really bad I'm just saying usually it
ends up just being something where
people are just not being straight up
with each other and I swear to God I
know everyone says it communication is
key and it really is that blunt of it
just talk also if you don't want to
break up and you want longevity for the
relationship you need to get to a place
where you're comfortable enough to have
the harder conversations in order to
move on yes okay best first date tips
how to handle a first date tips on how
to act okay wow well physically bring a
small perfume hold on let's just before
we even get there to perfumes and little
makeups and whatever First
Dates I would consider us to be
connoisseurs at them yes at this point
we're basically the Albert Einstein I've
seen every type of man behaving me in
every type of way mhm I've done some
foul things on first dates I will admit
but the best dates that I've had they
all have one thing in common they ask
questions and I think a lot of the time
I even used to do this I'd go into dates
so nervous what are we going to talk
about what if we have nothing in common
someone told me this and I've used it
ever since the one thing that people
love to talk about the most is themsel
so if you find any Lull in the
conversation or if you want to seem like
you're interested in them just keep
asking questions you cannot go wrong
with that yeah okay so my my tips
normally when I go into a first date
because I get really nervous and I tend
to either freeze up or talk too much I
have like little tricks I do before I go
into date to make it kind of feel better
before I go into it I kind of turn my
ner nerves into excitement so like make
sure I smile before I like even see the
guy like I'll kind of like smile think
like oh my God I'm going on a date so
the by the time I see him I'm already
kind of smiling and I'm kind of in a
better mood almost like faking it till
you make it and then also little tips if
you want to just like feel good
constantly buy a mini hair brush I
bought one of those foldable ones I have
a little mirror in it good keeper we're
in the car you got a little mirror two
mini perfume doesn't have to be the same
perfume just has to be in the same
family vanilla perfume vanilla mini
perfume do it I swear to God there is no
better compliment than a guy telling you
you smell good and by the way guys like
a good smelling woman typically vanilla
pumpkin flavor chai things that are a
little sweeter they do like sweeter I
don't know why birthday cake for some
reason they don't like it too strong
they like it just comforting and warm
and then three what was my last one I
had one in my
head I'll pick up on number three okay I
actually talked about this with my
therapist the other day so if you don't
listen to anything we say on this
podcast but this piece of advice it's
from a licensed therapist I was telling
her about how I was going on dates with
Mr Friday Mr Saturday we all know them
mhm and I was saying how excited and
nervous I was and I just want them to
like me and what do I wear and how
should I do my hair so that they like me
and she said I'm going stop you right
there my whole attitude before going
into a date was how can I present myself
in the way that I think that they'll
like me she said I want you to do
something different this time play your
favorite music make the getting ready
process enjoyable and fun because at the
end of the day it's fun you're going to
meet someone out it's a good time time
if it doesn't work out it doesn't work
out but you need to ask yourself this
question that I'm starting to do instead
of saying does he or she like me do I
like them do I want to continue seeing
them you are the prize baby you are the
prize you need to go into every single
date with that attitude that they are
lucky to have a few hours of my presence
we're going to have fun if it doesn't
work out whatever wasn't my person
exactly
yeah I love it thanks I love thanks what
are the signs that the relationship
isn't worth fighting
for I'll tell you the biggest sign and I
learned this when I watched a this is
actually a really good YouTube video if
you ever want to watch um this man who's
a divorce attorney talks he's in this
black and white video I need to get the
name of it I'll probably put in the link
because I loved learning about this um
and he talks about his cases and what he
thinks about marriage or relationships
and what he thinks has the chance of
working out versus like what didn't work
out like he it's really good and he's
worked with the most high-paying divorce
cases ever so he said that one of his
clients was in a relationship and he
asked them and there he was they were
getting a divorced and he asked the
woman cuz he was representing her and
said what was the moment that you
realized that the relationship was done
and she said this is a very botched
version of how it actually is but this
is part the essence of it she said that
he every morning would always make sure
that her granola was refilled even if it
was getting to the bottom it was like in
this clear container he would always
just look at it and not even have to ask
and just always refill it for her right
every morning he'd write these little
Post-its too for her when he was leaving
or whatever it was and she goes the day
I realized that a relationship even
after all these fighting he'd still do
it he'd still be that person there
consistently the day she knew that the
relationship was over was when he
stopped filling the granola stopped
doing the letters stopped doing every
little things that he used to do because
he stopped caring and it's the moment
you realize the relationship isn't worth
fighting for is when you realize that
that person just doesn't care it's
almost like they don't fight with you
because they don't care to fight anymore
you know you're just tired you give up
it's it's the giving up part and I think
that she realized in that moment that he
just didn't have anything left him to
keep the relationship
going damn right I was just going to say
do have been diagram that's always
helped me I think you know when you're
contemplating that idea of ending a
relationship with someone it's very
confusing and your head just is clouded
with all these different thoughts and
feelings and I love them but they did
this and I can only think of the good
times or the bad times I always find it
best when I put pen to paper and when I
real realized that I had no more fight
left in me was when I put a list of all
the things that I cannot live without it
that this person gives me and then all
of the things that pretty much keep me
awake at night and when I saw the cons
list was drastically longer than the
pros list I said okay all the things
that he's giving me right
now I'm actually able to give myself so
it's not worth it it's exhausting I just
realized one more thing sure that you
probably have the same thing with me is
another sign of knowing that the
relationship should end is what your
body is telling
you right so this is what's crazy is
that we were ugly at the end of our
relation what do you mean Sophia I had
sty I was in such shambles towards the
end of my relationship I had
sty look like a godamn ogre I had
literal sty you guys I couldn't even
blink I was a mess because it was coming
what did you have that was so bad so no
I'm I I had a bunch of things I had
stress rashes all over my stomach which
by the way I've never had stress rash
rashes all over my arms um UTI is
another sign that people get a lot um I
had a consistent headache I couldn't
sleep I got night sweats a ton like I
wouldn't have any stress which was
really R your body's literally saying we
don't even want to be in this
relationship where I would be totally
fine like the relationship was good
nothing was going wrong but in the
middle of the night I would wake up in
my clothes were drenched and that was
crazy so when your body physically is
with them and you realize you're doing
these like eye twitches like your
cortisols are high then get out I also
just thought of this other one
um maybe you weren't considering this
person that you're fighting for to
be your end all be all but if you
were I gave this visual to someone that
was
contemplating breaking up with the
person that they thought that they were
going to end up with and I said
okay close your eyes
picture you're in the delivery
room with your first
child and that guy or girl I'm assuming
we'll say husband and the husband is
there with you right and you have your
precious newborn that you just labored
48 hours for and you look to the
right and you see his family your new
mother-in-law and you have to hand away
this newborn to this part of the family
as well how do you
feel this person set him out
can't do it because you also have to
remember like you're May and all that so
if that's something that tickles your
fancy go for it but that's a good that's
a good visual um you seem a little
triggered by that one no I'm not um okay
this I can do this one um advice for
dating in college okay I dated in
college um Scarlett's currently dating
in college which is great and I we both
actually had really good relationships
in college I would say we found two guys
that were just awesome awesome to date
during those years and my advice is this
college is like a cesspool of people
that are just hooking up with each other
it is crazy everyone is in their late
teens early 20s no one's taking anything
seriously going to class yes you're wa
you're basically just you know it's like
a giant slumber party on campus 247
especially I went to USC it's the row at
USC at the time that I was there it
was it was wild I have stories there I
could probably share one day here but o
my advice is this and I heard this I
told sinee I heard this um on a real the
other day so I'm not taking credit for
thinking of this quote because I think
the best thing in college when you're
looking for a steady relationship a
steady one because as you know as a girl
when you're talking to guys that are in
college they're not really taking
anything seriously I heard this quote I
think that's kind of goes well with it
and someone told this woman stop looking
for a firework and start finding a
fireplace you got what I'm saying so my
voice I know that I thought you were
going to go somewhere so different with
this I thought this is going to be a lot
more profound God someone's asking about
college hookups and you're like be the
fireplace she wants a date and I said no
and this is my point is that a lot of
guys in college are going to give you
the butterflies the fireworks the rush
and they're going to call you they're
going to ignore you they're going to
hook up with you then they're going to
hook up with their friend and they're
going to sleep with you and then leave
the next it's crazy so if you want that
absolutely go get it cuz I know a lot of
girlfriends of mine did that but what I
loved about dating in college for me and
I know for scarlet was that we found the
one guy that wasn't the person that was
the craziest the loudest the I do have
to say
through seeing it not experiencing it
the first two years of college are
pretty much just fun dating whatever
junior senior year people started to
slow down so that's when you really
that's when I started to well I was sof
yeah so but you're so beyond my point
was is like my ex at the time in college
was like my fireplace he was my comfort
zone and I think that that's what you
really need to look for you don't look
for that guy that is like standing on on
like doing the a keg stand maybe he's a
fireplace too who knows maybe he was
just a little bit boozy that day
but what would
you I really had no idea where you were
going with this answer but isn't it C
kind of cute cuz we're always looking
for the guy that's laau us but we want
to find the home like the cracking of
wood but I would also argue you're not
going to find that in a frat house I
mean Scarlett did yeah but I did foret
forget it forget it just just don't
listen if you're a firework or a
firecracker or what' you say a fireplace
cracker jacker fantastic Okay Sophia all
right what would be a way to let someone
go specifically in a toxic
relationship here's what's funny when we
were breaking up with
people obviously we are the ones doing
it my dad would always say um never do
it in person always do it on the phone
which I don't agree with by the way I
don't agree with Sly was a dog for that
because by the by the way Chris every
time listen we've we've actually had
it's like every time we'd had to do it
on the phone and then they get so mad at
us we had to do no it's it's really it's
really bad it's really bad what horrible
advice do it on the phone it doesn't
matter who it is cu then you never you
can just hang up right if they start M
you just hang up they just say your
peace and you hang up they can't back
talk you block so that's one way to let
someone go that's one way to let someone
go block block them say your change your
Social Security change your address
change your name and just disappear text
them just write it out so you won't by
the way I'm really bad at verbalizing I
once oh my god when I was 15 I broke up
with a guy we went out for two weeks
it's fine but I called his home phone
his
landline and his dad answered I was like
hey can I talk to
Henry and then he was like I'm so
excited to see you was like yeah listen
and my mom was like vacuuming she's like
can you keep it down I'm like Mom watch
one minute I'll tell you the best the
best the best um on the phone one was
when uh sine she God what else no no no
no no it was I was ending it with
someone um this is like three years ago
and it was remember I was on a it was I
was in the kitchen you recorded me and I
could not verbalize what I was trying to
say and he literally you hear him on the
other side of the phone going uh I don't
get it like what are you trying to do
right now yeah contacts these are like
three to four dates yeah oh these are
not like people that we were seeing
seriously okay but a way to let someone
go I was watching this video earlier
today and this girl was very profound
she said that you need to ask yourself
certain
questions in your relationship and then
that sort of
determines whether you want to continue
with this person or not one of them was
and that really stuck out to me are you
in love with them or are you in love
with the potential that you put on them
or who they can grow to
be and if it's the
latter how do you do it you just have to
find neutral ground I don't like doing
things toxic don't don't do it in his
apartment don't do it in your place it
gets bad vibes you don't want to do it
in your place I also just think it's you
know what we even said the other day
Sophia and I went on a walk I said let's
go sit on this bench you know what she
said to me hm this would be a good
breakup
bench and let me tell you why she said
that we were on the West Side Highway
near the water it was quiet it was
Serene and then you guys can literally
just split after it's true someone can
just walk further downtown and someone
can just walk Uptown it was it was a
beautiful scenery it could it could calm
the nerves okay but a toxic relationship
public I just yeah my whole concern with
a toxic relationship is if you're going
to break up with someone your safety is
the most important thing and I know I
hate to bring it there but that's why
you want to do it in public in a place
that you feel safe and all eyes are
watching always have your girlfriend on
the phone or someone ready to go in case
you need them what to do if you're
getting mixed signals what to do if
you're getting mixed signals I've been
on this recent kick of just
um opening my big fat mouth and saying
exactly what the hell is up and before I
would just
let men confuse me and then I'd spiral
even more and try to do what they wanted
or tried to play their game as well now
I'm just so straight up and I'll just
say what are we doing here remember a
few episodes ago I asked that guy I said
what do you want from me and he said
nothing fine rejected I took it on the
chin but at least I got my answer and I
can move on also also I don't believe in
mix signals everyone knows what they
want the mix signals is just a delay of
the inevitable that's so true they know
what they want if I'm giving mixed
signals cuz I've by the way because I
was dealing with kind of a situationship
a couple months ago where I think I was
giving mix signals and I knew exactly
how I how it was going to play out so I
had to be the one to say hey this isn't
going to be what this is whoever side it
is just ask the question or say the
answer and it sucks it may hurt to hear
but would you rather be playing chess
for the next four years with someone who
isn't ready to commit or would you
rather just run the 60 yard dash get
kind of breathless and then you run down
the goal and then you win and the goal
the Finish Line the goal you had me at
the beginning of that I had I had in the
beginning not the 60 yard dash is that
even the thing still Sophia I know I
used to do 100 yard dash in high
school how to survive long distance and
this is the last question y'all how to
survive long distance I did it for a
year don't sorry
is that your personality that's the
first thing you need to ask yourself how
to survive L distance I would email Elon
Musk I'm talking and create delation
device stop no I was giving advice you
can't make stupid jokes this is serious
but you didn't do a long-distance
relationship I did but I'm telling you
my reasoning for never doing a
long-distance relationship okay you need
to ask yourself am I the type of
Personality where I can be away from my
partner for weeks even a month two
months at a time and feel secure not
worried feel just as love and affection
by them or if you're like me and I need
to be coddled six out of seven days of
the week I can't do it so I think if
you're the type of person that can
handle that great teach me yeah well so
I did a long-distance relationship it
was my first time it was across the
country so of course you know I will
tell you this that is one of the hardest
things I've ever had to do in a
relationship truly um because I am like
sust and at heart I love to be with the
person all the time but what worked out
definitely was setting a routine of
communication when it came to FaceTime
it was making sure that we were telling
everything to each other in the morning
everything to each other at night we
also had to have those serious
conversations a lot more frequent
because a lot of things can get lost in
the mix I was going to say there's a lot
more bickering a lot more because you're
not ble to physically be with the person
to see their body language or give them
a hug or I I'll tell you there was a lot
of bickers because of something that
someone said and it wasn't really what
they meant or vers vice versa like maybe
I said something that he interpreted
wrong and I was like oh that's not what
I meant and I would just say that that
the time that you do get with each other
my biggest recommendation is don't
overload it with a hundred fun things I
know that sounds weird I think at the
beginning it's really fun to visit and
then do a hundred fun things with each
other and then you have this like go go
go go mentality and then you go home and
you're exhausted I think the best way to
know someone is just being with them
24/7 maybe doing nothing because then
that really shows you do you see what
I'm saying sometimes I think like the
only way to survive a long distance
relationship is constant communication
through texting or calling pretty much
almost all day yeah cuz that's what how
much you would talk if you were in
person all the time anyway and then that
just avoids the what if the unknowns I
think also having an end to the long
distance like at least having an idea of
this is going to for both ends you both
want to come together at a certain point
I think if I knew that that would just
be a really nice you know piece at mind
this isn't forever get spicy on the
FaceTime I was going to say send photos
never send photos we don't know where
the cloud goes the cloud is somewhere
it's definitely not in the sky I don't
know we do you that
out we love you guys we hope you loved
our love filled episode please subscribe
to our YouTube we've unwaxed at
Instagram Tik Tok Apple podcast Spotify
five star reviews we love you we'll see
you next Tuesday bye bye